we are president that's the same I'm
free
first of all Jessie thank you so much
for doing this yes of course I'm so
excited to get to like hang out with
another writer yeah congratulations by
the way thank you I don't think I've
ever been this happy in my life
it never even crossed my mind that
miscarriage was something that would
happen to me it's so common and happens
to so many women but no one talks about
it
so one of those things that you just
don't think will happen to you until it
does you've been so open with your
pregnancy journey your fertility journey
what what's that been like for you and
why did he decide to be so public about
it I think what was really bothering me
was that every step of the way it was
kind of Dingell in my soul and I felt
myself not being myself anymore online
and I think people could feel that and
it almost had more power OFI to not talk
about it because it just felt like so
much my life that I've been Shing and so
much at that moment that I hadn't been
sharing and I just felt like was a way
to take my power back over the situation
minute I did so many women came forward
and talked to me about their stories
which was so full company I realized I'm
gonna love and a lot of us feel alone
during these kinds of situations and it
was just a beautiful thing and I've
never felt so light after sharing it off
so this is a new normal
how are you burnout obviously we're in
quarantine like being pregnant during a
pandemic I mean it has its pros and cons
I think I'm really happy that I got to
enjoy my pregnancy with so much time
Stephen and I slowed down because I feel
like we're all moving Lee all the time
and it kind of just button on everything
and you realize what really matters and
who I get out of breast just looking a
little bit right now that's a happy
but yeah we had all this time together
and I didn't have to go to any events
and hide or people question for me why
I'm not drinking and we just got to
really fight the news together for a
while so it's nice the calm I will say
is you know other enough allowing our
partners into any of the appointments
and for Steven and I this is our first
baby we've obviously been trying for so
long very exciting and we have to
FaceTime each other just like any old
Tristan outside it's really sad the role
is now that students don't allow to be
in my appointments with me I'm so
emotional we understand it's like for
safety but it's still it's very much
more us like we want to protect the
nurses and we're gonna abide by all the
rules that they give us but it doesn't
make it any less sad or like like more
emotional thankfully it's not as bad as
I imagined it when they gave me that
news we were still so excited and I set
up the camera and then paste in there
and they're like whatever we can do to
make this like better for you it's so
special yeah and they were like helping
me film and like it was really nice so
it went bad but it is you know you want
your partner there with you and he's
there
obviously he's outside just waiting for
you yeah he's he's not even allowed to
wait in the waiting room he has to be
like down in the parking garage oh he's
in the car yeah okay comes with wings oh
so it's nice
we're okay bring it too because we want
to get penned a little bit faster but
you have to understand if we put in to
both of them could be good and you could
be penned with twins that's not the end
of the world
some people prefer to get penguins yeah
we're not against ones during every
story you teased about implanting two so
that possibility of getting pregnant
right away what happened but there was
also a possibility there could be twins
yeah we didn't clear that up okay so
this is what happened we're kind of team
twin let's just you know maybe we can
just have twins and then be the doctor
really advised against it just because
of my size he says the chances of the
baby's being premature are much higher
it's still you just rather give me one
safe baby then you know two and then
some Poppins and the reason why put two
is just thought that people who do IVF
get pregnant with twins very easy and
the reason that happens is because when
you get your embryos some people don't
do genetic testing on them to infer that
they're all good so we actually the test
sure is ones we have and we're all good
so the chances of them sticking if we
put two is very high okay
I was like okay maybe not my first I
don't know if I would I don't know if
I'm ready for - so how did you go about
choosing the embryo that plan did you
like talk is it it was the male or
female you had to decide what was that
conversing with this well we just let
the doctor decide we told him like pick
the best king embryo and we'll just go
with that so we obviously know I'm
watching episode 5 last night I was like
boshu I saw your teaser you were wearing
pink girls having a girl and then I
would wait a minute I was reading your
comments everybody's commenting like
peachy
did they slit at all I went back and I
listened to comfort zones a kid may have
slipped
little worms the iWatch back and i still
don't see a slip there I think people
are interpreting as how they want at the
end of the tude gender sounds the same
you know what I mean when you say both
yeah she or he the very end soundless
I've been so good about everything what
I know that like that little sip would
like that little caffeine jolt wouldn't
make them like bounce around people are
kind of trying to figure out what it is
but uh I am really just looking for a
[ __ ] to reveal the gender and then I'm
just gonna do it so I really have a set
plan of when but I'm hoping it's soon
once the idea straights is this just
something special I was gonna actually
leave it in Monterey and then I decided
that I wanted a little piece of normals
and I wanted the element of surprise a
little to reveal moment so uh you're
going to do a gender reveal just with
the family or do you think did they all
already know or I don't know we go down
every no yes Leon oh my my very close
friends know and my mom knows they don't
know when they're just like dying
keeping the secret they hate it so much
yeah especially Katy she keeps who's my
best friend she keeps calling and saying
I can't take this people are
interrogating me but uh it's not really
so much a general Buell for my family or
for us it's just to go announce it we do
know the gender
we do it's gonna be an ongoing series
throughout the pregnancy yes we decide
that we're gonna keep it going and just
[ __ ] you meant our whole pregnancy
really excited for the birth episode you
know that's like exciting no yeah I
really love documenting it because even
for me watching it so special it's
probably the special thing I've ever
worked on editing it this is here's a
foot and you forget you go through and
you were feet playing it's feeling to
have it all talking when teaching the
baby Spanish of course yes
yeah the one thing my mom and I have
been doing is talking about oh we want
to speak horses in this together and I
have my aunt here who speaks Spanish so
I told them I'm like you can only speak
Spanish to the baby obviously you've so
many friends I'm a famous brand oh my
goodness this flower arrangement is so
amazing it's like the little top nut
it's literally my Silhouette baby bump
oh my gosh thank you so much Kylie this
is so sweet
Wow who are you most surprised reached
it out to give you consolation you know
there was a lot of people that surprised
me out of it a long list that I thought
it was so sweet when somebody surprises
you you're not that close with them I
got a really nice message from and occur
is such a sweet person and it it was
such a genuine beautiful message and I
loved that so that was really nice and I
think having the baby will impact your
work as an influencer I tell Stephen I
think I'm just gonna be holding the baby
and blending my eyeshadow while I film
my tutorial same time maybe
breastfeeding figure it out you'll be
fine I I think we've set some plans in
motion as to how we would maneuver it
also every late all your fiber go in
their growth and changing it's really
nice that we get
together will there be a maternity leave
a hiatus baby come on here right now I
don't know come on out you know I'm
working it's not my nature I don't know
if I could handle it but no I think by
the time the baby comes we'll be so and
hopefully this is all over we'll see
snow for me to just live life and be out
and do fun stuff and who will be in the
room when you're having the baby
that's right now we're only allowed to
have our partner you know
and so obviously see but you know if my
mom could be there too so we'll see does
he what does motherhood mean to you you
know I don't know yet fully yeah I've
always dreamt about it and before even
doing what I do now my dream was to be a
mother
and I have three brothers and I helped
my mom with them and seeing how they've
grown up and things took after me even
think I've taught them it's so special
and you really helped mold somebody and
just this unconditional love that I have
for them and I can't imagine what its
gonna be like when I have my own child
and get to do that with them
[Music]